Starlight starbrite first star I see
tonight I wish I may I wish I might have
you subscribed to film Theory
did it work
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the show who is your favorite Fearless
theorist do you guys see Puss and Boots
The Last Wish reviewing a word wow we
have come a long way from the original
Puss in Boots fresh roll and bean Club
you do not talk about Bing Club second
rule of being Club
about being Club needless to say I did
not go in expecting this new movie to be
all that great so DreamWorks basically
kicked down the door and said hey you
want to see something cool the story is
wholesome the characters are immediately
iconic and the animation man between
this film into the spider-verse and
Mitchells versus the machine Mickey and
the Gang gotta be quaking in their boots
Mouse in Boots in case you haven't seen
it yet The Last Wish follows our hero
cat as he realizes that he's on the last
of his nine lives and so he goes on an
adventure to find a fallen star that'll
help him wish those lives back but puss
isn't the only one who wants that wish
his former partner Kitty softpaws
Goldilocks and her three bears crime
family and the unapologetically evil pie
Baron Big Jack Horner are all after it
too oh my word it's the noble Phoenix
flame thrower right I love this guy he
is one of my all-time favorite villains
and if that wasn't bad enough a
mysterious hooded wolf wants to clean
puss's last life for himself why well
because he's deaf and I don't mean it
metaphorically rhetorically you're
poetically or theoretically or in any
other fancy way I'm deaf straight up yep
the physical manifestation of death
itself is after Puss in Boots because he
doesn't feel like puss is respected the
lives that he's been given that said all
of this about wishing for more lives and
death chasing him it's all a moot point
puss should already be dead his ninth
life is long gone forget the Tumblr sexy
man wolf or pie boy over there the
biggest threat is puss himself based on
everything that we see from him in this
movie he'd be dead multiple times over
by my count we're talking at least seven
and I don't mean stuff like riding
explosive fireworks or getting thrown
into signs that crash through windows or
anything like that no you see loyal
theorists almost every choice that puss
makes endangers his life death is
absolutely right about puss playing it
fast and loose with these lives but
we're not talking about the big picture
adventuring stuff I'm talking about all
the mundane everyday things that's
slowly killing this cat Puss in Boots is
wasting his final life and I'm about to
prove it to you grab your star maps and
your therapy dog's loyal theorists it's
time to dive in first of all let's just
start with what we see Puss in Boots
eating throughout the film see puss eats
and drinks a lot of stuff that would be
super unhealthy for a cat and before you
jump down into the comments section
telling me that this is just a cartoon
with a magic cat matpat need to stop
taking all these things way too
seriously first off do you know what
channel you're on secondly though we
absolutely should be taking a look at
what puss is eating and drinking because
we already know that it's straight up
was the cause of one of his deaths
during that opening Montage puss each
each eats shellfish during this opening
Montage puss eats shelf wow that is that
might be one of the hardest tongue
twisters in a long time during that
opening Montage puss eats shellfish and
dies as a result did it now it's played
for a joke in the movie but shellfish
allergies are definitely a thing that
can happen to a cat in fact many of the
symptoms are similar to what we see puss
dealing with in the film hives as well
as swelling of the face and limbs
admittedly death is a bit of an extreme
reaction to having this alley allergy
normally symptoms for cats are more mild
including hair loss rashes blisters
scratching though some cats do
experience respiratory problems as a
result of the swelling which can lead to
their death why am I bringing all that
up well because it shows us that Puss in
Boots is sensitive to this kind of stuff
and throughout the movie we see him
consuming a lot of stuff that would be a
no-go for a cat firstly we're talking
about puss's drink a choice creme or
milk I suppose we see him drink a lot of
it throughout the movie it almost seems
to have this alcoholic property for puss
but that's not how real cats react to
drinking milk according to the people's
dispensary for sick animals milk can be
bad news for our feline friends the
adult cats are lactose intolerant their
intestines don't have the enzyme lactase
which would help them break down the
sugars in milk and even if they could
physically drink it you probably
shouldn't be giving your cat milk anyway
milk is full of fat basically a saucer's
worth of milk would be the equivalent of
a human eating an entire 12 inch pizza
in a day and look at how much we see
Puss in Boots drinking in just this
movie alone
you I can't always lands on his I am
boots I am no one's love cat
do you see all those empty glasses on
the bar from this area wide shot I count
at least eight empty glasses plus the
one that he's working on and puss isn't
even done another glass of cream make it
your heaviest that right there is the
equivalent of puss eating nine plus full
pizzas worth of fat in just one sitting
this has come the day after he had yet
another milk binge so despite what all
the old cartoons said about giving your
cats milk as a treat do not do it it is
just super unhealthy and can lead to
cats becoming overweight and or their
early death so chalk up one extra death
for puss he met his maker through milk
but perhaps even worse than the milk
coffee in the opening fight against the
giant of Del Mar we see puss do this
caffeine is really unhealthy for cats to
the point that it can be seriously
dangerous for them to consume
considering their smaller bodies if you
want to know more about how crazy
dangerous caffeine can be in higher
doses with humans we actually just did a
video about that over on food Theory but
for a cat side effects from a cat
consuming caffeine includes an increased
heart rate abnormal heart rhythms
vomiting diarrhea tremoring seizures
according to the pet poison helpline a
moderate amount of coffee can easily
cause death in small dogs or cats now
before you start freaking out and hiding
all your coffee in a lock box away from
your animals a small sip of coffee
probably wouldn't impact a young healthy
animal too much but puss isn't that
young anymore so Downing an entire cup
of coffee like we see that is gonna be
bad news for this animal and might
literally have been the end of him if
the Bell didn't crush him to death mere
minutes later caffeine overdose death
number two but it's likely that puss
would have died long before this movie
in fact he would have died during the
promotional tour for this movie hey
what's going on everybody I'm Sean Evans
and you're watching hot ones it's a
pleasure I mean Eagle are you kidding me
a fictional cat got onto Hot ones before
me screw that noise look at my eyes are
you trying to kill me no but he's
killing me puss he's killing me but yeah
he's probably killing you too you see
the capsaicin and hot sauces as you
might guess dangerous for cats with
studies showing that it can constrict
breathing cause severe irritation in
their throats and digestive system and
in high enough doses cause death and
when you're talking about a 2 million
Scoville hot sauce yeah I'd say that's a
fairly high dose for a feline and then
of course you have the literal Tankard
of milk my kingdom heart attack
hot ones taking out puss's life before
he even knew he needed a Last Wish
Captain Calamity death number three
seriously Sean when you do eventually
have me on promise I won't make a mess
of your studio so okay clearly puss has
himself some dietary issues but there
are other choices that he makes that
probably would have gotten him killed a
lot sooner specifically the whole in
Boots thing sure your drip may be on
fleek their puss but you should not be
wearing all these clothes in your
particular line of work I don't know if
you've ever tried to dress up your cat
but they do not enjoy it in fact a lot
of experts recommend against dressing up
your cat at all mostly because it causes
them a lot of stress with no real
benefit other than some fake Internet
points for you there's a famous hat the
feather and of course the boots but even
if puss is the exception here and enjoys
his clothes his attire will have deadly
consequences let's just start from the
top shall we first of all the Hat this
one item of clothing would probably get
puss killed for two different reasons
first by wearing a wide brimmed hat like
puss does in the series he wouldn't be
able to take full advantage of his
whiskers you see cats don't see the
world the same way that we do they have
a whole Suite of abilities to help him
sense what's around him and their
whiskers are a crucial part of that
system the whiskers act like a sort of
radar able to sense changes in air
currents vibrations in the air they also
serve as the first level of alert if
anything gets too close to their face
additionally while a cat's long distance
eyesight is good at very close distances
they struggle to see anything that's
closer than 30 centimeters in front of
them as a result their whiskers help
them navigate that close-up World by
touching the whiskers against objects
they can tell where things are how big
they are even sensing their texture but
the hat is gonna stop all of that from
happening it's gonna change the airflow
It's Gonna Change vibrations it's gonna
prevent puss from getting his face close
to objects so his whiskers can touch him
basically the hat is going to be dulling
one of his most important senses or I
suppose I should say two of his most
important senses you notice what else
the Hat covers his ears that would be a
problem regardless of whether you're
talking about a human or an animal
basically you're just Muffler the sound
allowing enemies to more easily flank or
sneak up on you almost exactly like we
see death do in the movie if death here
didn't want to be so dramatic he could
have killed puss and gone about his
business without the cap being any the
wiser but the dulling of his hearing is
actually worse for puss because he's a
cat you see cats have some of the best
hearing of pretty much any animal you're
gonna have around the house with a wider
auditory range than both humans and dogs
but we're not just talking about better
hearing ranges cats have a lot of muscle
control over their ears and they're able
to turn their ears towards any source of
sound I don't know if you've ever
noticed that with any cats that you know
but if you make a sound in a quiet room
just notice how their ears are able to
Pivot in your direction like a big
antenna or a radar disc this cool
technique increases their hearing
sensitivity by 15 to 20 percent wearing
a hat is gonna eliminate all of that and
that's without even mentioning all the
other biological ramifications wearing a
hat basically Nerfs all of a cat's
hearing benefits and all of this is
without even mentioning the other
biological ramifications like the fact
that cats release a lot of their excess
heat when stressed through their ears
meaning that puss is going to be
sweltering in any battle he's in the
middle of all in all he may look dapper
but that's a hatastrophe that's waiting
to happen death number four similarly
puss's Cape is also going to be causing
him a massive problem for all intents
and purposes the Cape is Gonna Act Like
a collar but just much more dangerous
than a normal collar see though putting
a collar on your cat is usually fine and
helps identify your feline friend to
strangers they can be dangerous in
specific situations if they become
snagged on some sort of object like a
branch or a rock then the cap might be
choked or strangled the Cape is going to
present all of the exact same problems
but 10 times worse because it's just a
bolt of fabric that's hanging from his
neck puss's Cape is just an open
invitation for him to be caught and
choked especially in a fight with an
enemy who's smart enough to just grab
the thing and wouldn't you know it
that's exactly what we see happen in
this new movie
honestly Edna Mode from The Incredibles
been right about this one for decades
not kicks death number five No Escape
for this cape but perhaps the worst in
this whole attire the boots you ever
notice how cats try to get anything
that's stuck on their feet off Puss
himself literally does this in the movie
when he's forced to wear those little
kitten mittens
stupid mittens cats don't like have
their paws covered for a lot of reasons
some of them are kind of mundane like
the fact that there are scent glands in
their paws that help him mark their
territory they're also comforted by
kneading their little cat beans on their
owner's stomachs but other reasons are a
lot more serious the most obvious one is
that paw pads are a massive shock
absorber they help cats remain quiet and
stealthy cats literally evolve to walk
on their toes so they can move more
silently changing that up to loud heavy
boots click clacking as puss moves
around is gonna give up a massive
natural advantage that cats have as
Fighters another problem cats actually
sweat through their paws mostly when
they're nervous ever take your cat to
the vet notice that there's damp little
Footprints everywhere so if Puss and
Boots ever gets anxious or scared he's
gonna basically be standing in a pool of
his own sweat in the boots on top of
getting himself a case of sweaty palms
and dropping a sword everywhere huh what
if we've ever seen that in the movie
foreign
but not only is it a problem in battle
it's also just unhealthy for puss
sweating helps regulate your body
temperature cooling You by evaporating
on the skin this works the same way with
the sweat coming from cat paws but it
simply wouldn't be possible if two of
puss's Paws were in leather boots that
don't breathe at all they'd be sticky
and gross and wouldn't help him cool off
and if anyone is in need of staying cool
it's pushed trust me I run hot without
the ability to sweat unimpeded puss is
running the risk of overheating
especially during those anxious fits
after he fights death and on top of all
of that just like the Hat cover in his
ears covering up puss's paws are also
going to be a massive disadvantage when
it comes to his senses not super common
knowledge but cats actually have tiny
tactile hairs between their paw pads
that act similarly to whiskers these
hairs not only act as a protective
covering against debris chemicals or
exposure to the elements but along with
nerve receptors in the pads themselves
they let the cat know a lot about the
ground that they're walking on what sort
of material is it what's the temperature
with the boots he's losing basically all
of the feedback that cats get it from
their paw pads and the hairs touching
the ground in short it's a recipe for
death number six death and Boots so is
that it it is vet Barber have the right
idea in the film when he said that puss
should abandon his outfit and retire
that he should be living out his life
with that old woman Mama Luna lounging
around the house as a normal house cat
well not exactly resigning himself to a
life of pickles who told you the name
may just have been the most dangerous
thing for him in the movie see despite
this being the simple easy life for Puss
and Boots he should not be spending his
Sunset years with Mama Luna and it all
comes down to one super simple thing
poop you see despite being played as a
joke in the film there's only one litter
box in her entire house only one a
single box for how many cats does she
have dozens at least if you pause the
movie at this wide shot you can count at
least 45 cats in the house including
puss frankly that is just far too many
calf to be sharing a single litter box
unless Mama Luna's cleaning that box
every single time a cat goes potty which
she is definitely not given how gross
that thing looks and how comically long
the queue is to use it the cats are
gonna be actively stepping in each
other's waist not only is that just
disgusting this setup would create a hot
spot for the spread of disease between
the cats the most serious of these
fecal-borne diseases is the type of
coronavirus infection that can mutate
into feline infectious peridentitis or
FIP a disease that's commonly fatal to
cats so yet again puts shoes in this
life would probably have also led to his
premature death death number seven one
crappy way to die honestly if puss
really wanted to choose a life that
wouldn't be courting death that wouldn't
be putting him in constant danger for no
reason he just needs to be a normal
house cat so puss hang up your sweaty
boots and your sound dampening hat and
find yourself a nice old lady who
doesn't have 44 other cats all in all by
my count plus probably should have died
a total of seven extra times than we see
recounted in the movie in total we're
talking about 15 deaths looking at it
that way a sickle carrying wolf in a
unicorn horn crossbowing Maniac were
probably the least of puss's concerns
really when it comes to valuing your
life a lot of times it's the little
things the small everyday decisions that
ultimately add up to the life that's
well lived maybe that's why Wolfie was
following him the whole time it wasn't
to punish puss for his Reckless
adventuring but instead to consult him
on proper dress and a heart-healthy diet
to keep him alive longer seriously even
if he got his wish for another Nine
Lives he'd still only have three
remaining why not ask for like I don't
know a hundred extra lives there puss I
guess counting really isn't your strong
suit but hey speaking of cats needing to
eat better so they can live longer
healthier lives let's talk about Meow
Mix the sponsor for today's episode in
case you don't know Steph and I have a
cat named skip who's been a part of our
lives and these channels for a long time
foreign
long enough that he's not impressed with
all that much anymore just look at that
face you know how a lot of things tend
to get overwhelmed well that right there
is one entirely welmed cat he's been
plenty of places and he's definitely
seen some things but one thing that
still gets skip running is dinner time
with Meow Mix every day boom highlight
of the day he is right there at that
bowl enough so that and I'm not making
this up when Meow Mix actually sent us a
bunch of product just to film with he
literally ripped into one of the bags
that they sent us just to get at the
food he was that excited and honestly we
couldn't be happier Meow Mix is the
perfect food for skip despite his
impressive bite strength skip snow
spring chicken anymore he's now 12 years
old and we want to make sure that he's
able to stay healthy and strong Meow Mix
original choice has a hundred percent
complete and balanced nutrition
providing him with every essential
vitamin and mineral he needs but it's
also packed with protein to help keep
his muscles strong on top of all of that
Meow Mix comes in a ton of different
flavors as well as both wet and dry
Foods so if cat's a picky eater or you
just want to change it up and expand
their flavor palette there's something
here designed to satisfy even the
pickiest of kitty cats so if you want to
make sure that you're giving your cat
food that they're gonna love check out
Meow Mix in all its varieties by
clicking the link down in the
description again thanks to Meow Mix for
sponsoring today's episode we appreciate
it and Skip really appreciates it
as always my friends remember it's all
just a theory a film Theory and cuts